we keeping score on this cuz I am cuz
your weight I've not said horny
is as horny does in the sweetly absurd
high school comedy easy give us hints
you can give it back to actors yeah and
I just think that I don't ever need to
cook tiramisu
you may go in for the sicko laughs but
you'll exit with a big goofy grin and
warmed that says cockles here but I
think that might be cackles the best of
both worlds American Pie it was like
because it's like raunchy but feel good
it's absolutely magical
much like Heath Ledger's face 10 Things
I Hate About You that's him in that
movie sweet love renew by force
hey don't say [ __ ] like that to me
people can hear it if I see one more
high school movie that uses a literature
class Shakespeare lesson as a metaphor
for raging hormones and whatever else
the screenwriter is trying to put across
I swear I'm gonna throttle someone I am
just quote well I can't I've never seen
that movie Witherspoon has the most
expressive pair of nostrils in the
business election election of course
he's like our queen but maybe have
certain older wiser people hadn't acted
like such little babies and gotten so
mushy then everything would be okay
glistening behind a shiny Barbie doll
smile this central character is
completely unafraid to kiss you on the
cheek while planting a nice square in
your back
the girls Oh Regina Regina sweet sweet
red boo you [ __ ] Blanc knows precisely
what sort of show it is and it's not
afraid to poke some fun at itself while
always being sure to deliver the
well-scrubbed teenage angst want to
invite you to dinner family
sex lies and a webcast are some of the
ingredients in this zippy teen comedy
that says fresh is a tropical cocktail
garnished by an outrageous swizzle stick
easy yes
webcam we are officially over Oh Brad
the fact that you instantly liked these
spoiled little rich kids is a testament
to this woman's skills as a screenwriter
clueless woo Amy Heckerling the single
finest movie of the 80s club
[Music]
that's it we finish today very well
Wow I mean it only went well because
they were here and I contributed nothing
well well we got it and wrong
[Music]